hey guys I'm Ryan right IO I'm Jerry yes
you are
we're gonna check out this video that
was sent to us Avengers of Oz age of Tin
Man the cliff raises of a very lumpy
title the following makes no sense I
love that alright let's watch this I
want to see this is about to do it I'm
gonna show you something beautiful
strings strange
ha
there are no strings on me
that's pretty awesome that wasn't bad
dude that wasn't bad at all
like I see a lot of these like sliced
taking people's faces and putting it
over Avengers I see a lot of those kinds
of things that was executed really well
that's funny though I enjoyed that quite
a bit yeah they were able to really put
together it looked kind of real at times
I like the color tinting they did with
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch that was
really funny
good job man proud of you Thanks we like
the age of Ultron so that was a nice
little treat and [ __ ] Tin Man looks
scary at the end yeah
when was the Vaz of the classic it's a
classic and this guy knew what he was
doing anyway guys thanks for tuning in
if you needed the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out Gerry on this channel reasons
to Jerry and ain't gas dubs fun [ __ ]
there and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter and vine or we didn't
have followers we can get more product
placement for things such as I don't do
bear oh cuz it's here err dildos they
float and fly right into the vagina or
butthole no they're like hoverboards I
just what as dildos or they weren't like
Thor's hammer it slides here only if
you're worthy well they're really enough
to use the tilt up what does that
involve how do you become worthy after
to use a dildo you gotta be willing to
put two dildos in your butt that's one
of the rules double well I'm not worthy
I'm worthy I know you are there's some
kinky [ __ ] yeah I have to go get a
colonoscopy tomorrow some rectal damage